cherry Macaulay NBC Sunday Night
Football rules analyst former NFL
official who joins us on the program
Terry good morning I've been railing on
this fumbling out of the end zone for a
few years now we saw it again last night
I saw you had some tweets I'm assuming
we're on the same page of how do we
change this rule and if we do what do we
do with it well good morning Dan but for
my tweets how can how can you think
we're on the same page
in fact it's taken me to now to get to a
decision I think I've heard your
arguments I've heard a lot of the
arguments and it's they're pretty strong
to that we need to change this but I
think the play last night dan I think
it's the one that that finally got me to
say the rules right where it is and I'll
tell you I think because the end zone is
special and and what what the the north
of Saints player did last night was very
risky I think it's safe to say when you
reach the ball out that you're you have
a you're creating a really great risk of
losing it because especially through the
end zone because you lose the ball okay
but the reward you know is pretty great
the ultimate reward is six points you
don't get a bit of reward and in the
game of football so it's it's a risk
reward situation I'm gonna risk taking
the ball out from under my arm where
it's great control and I'm probably not
going to lose it to putting it out there
where the the Carolina defender last
night made a great play knocked it out
so you would you need the rule as it is
you wouldn't change anything
I would not Dan okay you were ordered to
come up with a way to modify it what
would be the alternative I I think you
to be consistent
I don't like special rules in in general
so I think I'd want to be consistent
with the current possession rule out of
bounds to fumble it forward out of
bounds you just bring it back to the
spot I don't but I think if you make it
up and you let's put it that analyst for
the 20 let's let's do something else
that seems to be something that you just
make up and to figure out well we needed
to change it and let's do something that
seems
reasonable I I don't like that concept I
like consistency and and bringing it
back to the spot would would be the most
consistent answer yeah I was even saying
if you let's say I'm diving for the
pylon and I'm trying to score and the
ball goes out of bounds through the end
zone mm-hmm now I'm I'm gonna be
penalized for trying something you know
to try to score touchdown no nobody
nobody did it I you know I can be diving
lose the ball and a deep defenders not
even there so is the rule applicable to
something like that III think it is I
don't lose the football fumbling is one
of the worst things you can do I mean
that's that's you you deserves something
bad to happen to you and you know in
most cases if you fumble the football
and and I just think if you make it less
less likely to lose the football then we
may see more fumbles because they may
try some things unintended consequences
okay so we're not on the same page and
that's fine but you'll come around
eventually when they change the rule I
did on the extra point I didn't like
that when they moved it to the 15-yard
line years a few years ago but I have
come around there because Terry if you
started out and you said okay we're
gonna have the rules of football and
we're gonna put in something a rule for
an extra point where 99% of the time
it's successful mm-hmm can you think of
another rule in any other sport
where you have a rule where you go 99
percent of the time you're going to be
successful and that's why I always
wondered with the extra point why it was
you know almost a guy pedestrian like
like I can kick an extra point you know
this is 99 percent of the time so that's
why I wondered if you came up with the
rules of football now you would never
have an extra point at you know where it
was at the two and a half yard line and
you're right and I've come around to
that viewpoint I think it's exciting
that we have missed extra points now
here's another thing we're talking to
terry macalmon BC Sunday Night Football
rules analyst former official
is it an offensive lineman can't hold
rank
he's not supposed to be able to hold he
can't grab and pull but a defensive
lineman can grab and pull
correct correct if he's trying to get to
the runner yes if he's trying to get to
runner get through that block you can
grab and pull him out of the way yes
okay but so they're they're they're
combatants so I got an offensive lineman
who can hold a defensive lineman who can
hold correct situations where the
defensive lineman cannot hold if you've
got a center trying to get out to block
to the second level you know he can't be
grabbed and held and restricted from
getting out to that second level block
it is illegal to do that why don't we
just eliminate all offensive holding
well because I really like defense and
and I don't want to get to a point where
it's like a game of horse and basketball
with two great shooters and you just
stay there all day til somebody misses
if you allow the offense to hold the
quarterback every quarterback whether
that be the worst quarterback I've ever
seen if he has long enough to throw the
football he's going to be look like a
great quarterback so I got to get
something to the defense oh I'm all for
that but it that's we're well past that
because you know and then once we get to
the postseason it feels like every year
the the postseason officiating feels
different than the regular season
whether it is conscious or subconscious
here did you feel that way when you were
officiating I didn't and and I'm gonna
speak for myself mostly but you know I
obviously have a lot of friends
officiate as well for me every play was
the same
it didn't matter it was week one of the
pre preseason week one a regular season
last play the Super Bowl it's just for
those seven seconds I'm working the play
based on the guidance and the rules I've
got and I'm going to make a judgment as
best I can do do maybe you you you give
a little extra effort to make absolutely
certain which you really should do every
play that you don't make an incorrect
call that may come into play
subconsciously as they come in as you
know as
you know the pressure of the playoffs
but it really should it really needs to
be the same for every single play and
and and I do I do a spy I do I do
believe that the teams are better in the
playoffs you're going to get better
football and you're going to have less
less chance of fouls I mean on Sunday
Night Football we've had the best teams
and we don't have very many fouls on
Sunday Night Football what rule do you
think will be changed in the offseason
hmm
or should be is a great question
III don't think it'll change the use of
helmet but they're going to they're
gonna have a lot better guidelines in
the off seasons I think there's a chance
and and and now that I mentioned that I
do think there's a chance they may bring
replay in for player safety fouls I've
just come around to that to that
conclusion myself I I just think it's
time when it's player safety the Michael
Thomas hit last night I believe that's
what was they just missed it and I don't
think you can miss those plays anymore
but explain how you would try to enforce
this or police this well I I think when
it comes to is there a foul for a hit on
an illegal hit on a defenseless player
is it a clear and obvious play where
that we've seen where he lowers the head
he approaches lowers the head and makes
forcible contact to the by the runner or
to the runner then I think you know
replay should have without coach's
challenge the ability to to make sure
that that player is penalized again it
would have to be very narrowly written
maybe a lot smarter Minds then than I
have or that I am could come up with the
exact way to do it but it we just can't
we can't have some of these that's and
that any officials on the field do get
most of them but the misses are so
glaringly obvious that I don't think we
can keep doing that have fun on Sunday
night it'll be the Chiefs at the
Seahawks Thierry safe travels and thanks
for joining us as always thanks very
much Dan that's Terry McCauley NBC
Sunday Night Football rules analyst
former NFL official and we're not on the
same page
or Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]